CBS News Royal contributor Tina Brown
has been covering the royal family for
the past three decades her most recent
book is called The Palace papers Tina
good morning to you good morning we sort
of suspect it was going to be a
different kind of day as Holly pointed
out when the doctor said because they
never say anything that they were
concerned but Tina I kept holding on to
the words that she's resting comfortably
but you knew that you knew that this was
probably a very bad sign this was
clearly a holding phrase while the
family gathered gathered together
because
they do not they do not the palace you
know issue those kind of bulletins
unless it's dire yeah and we had just
seen the queen yeah two days before yes
the story she managed to do that she
managed to greet her new prime minister
uh she had hung in the queen yeah and
she was working right up to the end but
you know this is what was so fascinating
to me so many people were still in shock
and caught off guard caught off guard
and still really reeling and were not
prepared do you think she was prepared
on some level she's 96 years old the
queen has been very much prepared really
for the last couple of years since
really October of last year when she
went into the hospital for unannounced
tests that she had she has known that
she had an underlying condition and she
has been preparing for this moment in
her typically stoic and stalwart fashion
we've seen for instance doing her doing
a lot of Estate Planning in June of this
year earlier she announced that Camilla
would henceforth when the queen when
Charles takes over would be known as the
queen concert that was her sort of
taking that slightly controversial issue
off the table for Hassan and making sure
that was all cleaned up we've seen her
meeting at Balmoral over several days
with prince Andrew which was clearly
about what are we going to do with
Andrew now let's just finally sort this
out it was being at Balmoral important
to her and did she want to get through
the Jubilee she always
had hoped she said to people who know
her well to diet Balmoral that was her
her most private of Estates that's where
she hoped that she would pass actually
and it has indeed gone according to plan
what was really important to the queen
was that she got through uh her Jubilee
her Platinum Jubilee celebrating 70
years on the throne and it was touch and
go through that period about you know
she didn't manage to get to all the
events but she went to the important
ones on the balcony and you know the
beginning and the end of the Jubilee
though she couldn't make it to the
church service and there were other
things that she couldn't get to but that
was so important and then of course when
we saw the transfer of power with Boris
Johnson she wanted to meet her last
prime minister let's trust her from
Winston Churchill to lose indeed wow
the the popularity of the queen
something we've touched on earlier this
morning uh it is worth lingering on
three out of four Britain's
proved of what she did her performance I
mean that's up there with the approval
rating for chocolate so how was she able
to do that
she understood how to play the long game
and you know her
Fidelity to duty was absolutely Ironclad
she really never let the country down
she really didn't she put it first she
you know she subsumed her own private
desires and passions to serve her
country the interesting thing is that
you know unlike really everybody else in
the royal family at times I mean she has
always seen the duties the Royal duties
that we think of as perhaps so
desperately boring she didn't find them
boring she actually loved her job Holly
Williams said in her piece that she was
an impossible act to follow as we look
at who's next how will things change and
is the monarchy possibly at stake now
that the queen is gone
well no one is ever going to have again
I think the Queen's Mystique just
because of the circles of History around
this woman as you say from Winston
Churchill to Liz trust and social media
Tina and social oh my gosh we knew
nothing about the queen and that was her
great strength and she preserved that
Mystique by understanding that not
speaking was the way for her to preserve
that that uh you know Wonderful mystery
that she still presented to the public
so she is a very hard act to follow I
mean in many ways it's not it's not bad
a bad thing that Charles actually is as
old as he is it will be a transitional
role you know his his job mostly will be
to prepare the monarchy for his son
William yeah I mean it's such a
different time
yes it's a very different time but
there's really never been in England uh
that has in Australia but not in England
that has no current no modern uh serious
movement to abolish the monarchy
um I think particularly in an era when
politicians become less and less popular
the the whole uh uh concept this a
thousand-year-old institution that sits
above politics exactly and keeps sort of
over Mighty politicians in their place
becomes actually increasingly appealing
you know I'm still I'm struggling
politics and being outside a party
actually is the key I'm struck by the
word Duty because you know we keep
talking about the Queen's Duty Julian
Payne who was just here said that for
Prince Charles this is a matter of Duty
do you think for him this is a matter of
Duty or do you think that he is
he has been waiting for this moment what
do you think well I mean Charles has
been waiting and waiting I mean he's
been in the ante room of his Destiny you
know for 50 years all right and there
have been times recently when he stood
in for the queen like in the opening of
parliament when frankly with the crown
sitting next to him on a velvet cushion
I thought he was looking a little
longing do you think he wants it yes
he's always wanted it but like many
things that happen too late which it is
really I'm sure that he also has at this
point great anxiety and mixed feelings
because in fact he has really very
successfully reinvented the role of
Prince of Wales which was kind of a
nothing rule until him yeah no I mean he
created so much good with his Prince of
Wales trust charity and with his
remarkable uh you know sort of promotion
if you like of of climate change
concerns and the things that really he
cares about he'll have less Freedom as
king and he knows that well as a lesson
he learned from his mother he was asked
by a documentarian a few years ago if
he'll continue the activism and he said
no I'm not stupid
there's a lot to see and to follow up
Tina Brown we thank you so much for your
Insight